euh ma mère est terrifiée par une
arrestation possible par les Allemands
toujours pris entre mes sentiments
patriotiques français qui sont très
forts et la volonté de découvrir tout ce
que font ces jeunes officiels qui
occupent la France entre
1914 et 1918 heureux c'est ça ce qui
marque la vie d'un enfant même le choc
quand même que représentait
l'arrestation de ma sœur je ne n'en ai
pas compris la gravité j'ai cru qu'elle
allait revenir quand une fois ma mère
imaginait le pire mais on était très
très peu informé vous vous souvenez la
façon dont vous a dit que votre père et
votre sœur restez à Toulouse avait été
arrêté
on a dû nous l'écrire ma sœur aînée qui
était cachée sous un faux nom dans une
autre ville a dû la prendre elle a
essayé de nous venir en est dans nos en
voyant un petit peu d'argent et je pense
que le fiancé de l'époque de ma sœur
déportée qui nous a envoyé sa bicyclette
quelques effets dans une caisse nous a
expliqué tout cela en fait mon père
avait été informé je ne sais comment que
il était menacé d'une arrestation et
avec un peu de légèreté je dois dire il
s'est déplacé de la banlieue de Toulouse
que le Miet vers Lourdes et il a été
arrêté à lourdé entre temps les gens qui
sont venus de l'arrêter à Colomiers près
de Toulouse ont emmené ma soeur ma soeur
n'a pas su mon père allait être arrêté à
son tour un tout petit peu plus tard et
à la fois confusément elle lui en
voulait en même temps elle croyait lui
avoir sauvé la vie quand elle reviendra
elle sera très très choquée d'apprendre
qu'en fait
mon père a été lui-même arrêté et que
dès le jour de son arrivée à Birkenau il
a été conduit vers la chambre à gaz
encore une fois je l'ai dit n'avait pas
une santé excellente il pouvait pas
servir de d'esclaves travailleurs et
voilà à quel moment après la guerre
est-ce que vous avez appris qu'elle
avait été les parcours exacts de votre
sœur et surtout de votre père puisque
lui n'est pas revenu parce que revient
elle fait partie des 2500 rescapés sur
75000 juifs arrêtés déportés en France
elle parle un peu je dis un peu parce
que pendant des années c'est déportés
ont une chape de plomb une impression
qui n'intéressait pas vraiment et puis
non non peut-être même pas réalisé
eux-mêmes s'il y avait le monstrueux
dans le fait qu'on les avait privés
toute humanité quoi sur mon père on
apprendra petit à petit
que effectivement il a été gazé dès son
arrivée et on le saura par un des
rescapés aussi qui sans être de la
famille est une relation qu'on a et qui
était connu et de nous et qui viendra
qui viendra dire ça ce qui fait qu'on
d'attrape la mort de mon père de février
au de mars 1943 et au moment où je
deviendrai pupille de la nation et
[Musique]
on parle de tout ça mais on n'insiste
pas sur les horreurs de tout ça il
faudra que j'atteigne l'âge adulte et
beaucoup plus tard pour réaliser tout ce
que ça représentait de de souffrance et
de douleur nous vous souvenez la
dernière fois que vous avez vu votre
père
ah je me rappelle très très bien la
dernière fois que j'ai vu mon père c'est
quand il m'a raccompagné dans le Berry
je ne peux pas le dater exactement à mon
avis c'est au cours de l'année 1942 et
je revois son image toujours très très
clairement c'est sa voix qui a disparu
et encore une fois je pense que
il y avait entre moi et mon père un lien
étrangement beaucoup plus fort qu'entre
moi et ma mère mon père représentait le
rêve
et donc
le fait de prendre conscience petit à
petit que je l'ai perdu conscience que
que je repoussais je veux dire je
faisais des vœux sur son retour à chaque
étoile filante qui passait dans le ciel
et tout en me réjouissant bien sûr de ce
que ma sœur était revenue dans mon
esprit d'enfant c'était assez étonnant
que ma sœur que je considérais comme
fragile et puis revenir et que mon père
que à tort je considérais comme fort ne
revienne pas j'ai mis très très
longtemps à accepter cette idée qu'il ne
fallait plus l'attendre quand vous
pensiez à votre père à partir de 1942 où
est-ce que vous l'imaginiez
j'avais aucune idée concrète de ce qui
avait pu lui arriver encore une fois je
suis à loi sur Arnon un village perdu du
Berry il n'y a pas de journal ou plus
exactement il y a un journal qui paraît
tous les 15 jours qui je crois s'appelle
le petit Nouvelliste du centre où on ne
parle que des vaches qui ont volé dont
les veaux sont en vente enfin des
informations de ce genre rien rien rien
ne me parvient tout est abstrait pour
moi tout m'arrivera dans la figure après
la guerre et m'arrivera par paquet
d'informations comme ça
vous parle des déportations est-ce
qu'elle m'aime est au courant des
arrestations de ces choses-là ou pas ma
mère est terrifiée par une arrestation
possible par les Allemands c'est tout
mais ça ne rentre pas
dans une explication détaillée il ne
faut pas être arrêté il faut échapper à
la station mais je la revois par contre
encore une fois non seulement ce sera
pas la poitrine par des prières mais
persuadé qui qui a un danger que je
m'entête à ne pas vouloir comprendre et
d'enfant un plusieurs reprises vous avez
parlé de l'importance de l'école de
votre relation avec cette instituteur et
puis plus tard au collège de votre
relation forte avec Monsieur gala est-ce
que dans ces années-là vous qu'est-ce
que représente dans ces années là
l'importance d'apprendre d'apprendre le
français est-ce que c'est un moyen
d'échapper à votre vie qui n'est pas
très heureuse
notamment en raison de des événements
qui frappent votre père de la peur
d'être arrêté
français ma langue maternelle je
rappelle que je suis né à Paris et j'ai
même calculé que je n'avais pas été
conçu dans le train que j'étais sans
doute la dernière occasion de
rapprochement de mes parents
bah le français me fascine comme il
fascine je crois beaucoup malgré tout de
petits immigrés et j'ai beau être né à
Paris je suis quand même un enfant
d'immigré sur une langue que j'aime qui
me paraît magique j'ai une envie de
lecture d'autant plus forte que la
lecture et le seul moyen non seulement
d'éducation mais de distraction à cette
époque la télévision n'est pas inventée
nous n'avons pas de radio
il y a pas de journaux bon le livre quel
qu'il soit c'est toujours un objet
magique pour moi
non les choses me paraissent naturel
c'est ma curiosité bon individuelle j'ai
envie d'en savoir plus
c'est une bulle qui vous protège du
monde extérieur l'école le collège
l'apprentissage
l'école dans la vie d'un tout petit
village est évidemment le moment fort
il y a rien d'autre à faire qu'elle est
à l'école ou participer aux travaux des
champs comme peuvent le faire des
enfants tout petits dans les dans les
villages je me rappelle même sur ce
travail d'aide en marche de battage du
blé avoir gagné un jour un billet de 5
francs 5 centimes aujourd'hui en France
en France courant ou constant et avoir
tendu bravement ce billet à ma mère
alors que les paysans locaux sans y voir
ma liste ça devait les faire rire
m'avait saoulé à mort et que je
vomissais de tout côté un vin rouge qui
n'était pas de Bordeaux
[Musique]